les allées se remplissent peu à peu
dégustation de bon matin ou découverte
des animaux de la ferme petits et grands
sont contents de revenir pour la 58e
édition du salon de l'agriculture
après deux ans de fermeture à cause du
coc vide 19 au pavillon 3 du côté de la
région ile de france les gourmands se
retrouvent pour goûter du miel aussi que
le miel soit pas seulement un produit
consommation j'ai mal à la gorge et je
prends de lumière c'est aussi un plaisir
qu'on se donne à déguster du miel qui
reçoivent nature avec du fromage avec de
la viande xx e façon des yaourts sont
mes yaourts au lait entier de poules et
de vaches de de notre ferme parce que
nous sommes éleveurs producteurs et
transformateurs directement à la ferme
ou encore des cookies le best seller
chez pierre et ims et le trois chocolats
donc chocolat blanc chocolat noir
chocolat au lait sont des chocolats en
provenance de cacao barry qui sont faire
découvrir dans les yvelines pendant ce
temps ça s'active au pavillon 1 au
niveau du grand ring 44 jeunes de 16 à
24 ans s'affrontent pour tenter de
devenir le meilleur jeune berger de
france manon batista et lauriane conseil
élèves en bts production animale à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
représenter l'île de france c'est plus
compliqué que les autres cas de
sélection parce qu'on est avec des
jeunes
des personnes qui sont dedans et qui
sont eux aussi fort que nous et
passionné donc c'est plus compliqué mais
on va faire sa place un concours qui
constitue une superbe opportunité pour
ces deux jeunes femmes de 20 ans ça leur
permet d'échanger avec d'autres jeunes
d'autres établissements d'autres régions
aussi de france et de rencontrer des
professionnels qui sont tous ultra
bienveillant qui leur donne quelques
conseils donc ça c'est bien pour elle
aurait pu arriver seul salon franchement
c'est c'est juste super et enfin je le
souhaite à tout le monde j'avais un peu
de hantise mais on voit que les gens
sont tous se stresser aussi et du coup
on se sent bien au centre et des noms
c'est celle et c'est génial fin de
journée les épreuves sont terminés et
les résultats tombent manon et la 21e
meilleur jeune bergère de france et
lauriane arrive en 35e position
une journée mémorable pour les deux
jeunes femmes et si vous ne vous êtes
pas encore rendus au salon de
l'agriculture où vous avez encore le
temps il se poursuit jusqu'au 6 mars